oh I'm here to be the best goddamn snake
this town is let's go yeah yeah gonna
get the longest [ __ ] snake oh my god
yeah baby you know all of them I never I
never oh I got one
[ __ ] get Rick [ __ ] damn I'm long we're
gonna take over this server bros God the
it's it's lagging don't join the game
goddamn it
Oh what the [ __ ] here - penis will rice
again here we go come on baby more glowy
[ __ ] this the most quality game hey how
did you speed up what the [ __ ] how do
you do that
the PT penis does not have that ability
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh how does he do that
there's someone just died oh my god this
is amazing
nevermind [ __ ] me do I suck ass we're
gonna be the longest snake
this town is yeah Oh keep growing baby
keep growing
yeah so you can go through yourself with
your penis that's good that sounded
weird oh my god
yes oh my god oh my god many vato hell
you bet that's Weiss is so hard why is
being a dick so hard that was a good one
[Music]
zero deaths all right Ethan Bradberry go
oh my god
gold mine gold mine suck my ass
there it is paratis we're [ __ ] long
and hard baby that set we're long and
hard I'm not gonna die from a tiny
little nub penis that said babe yeah you
want to fight because you did too
[Music]
damn it you see this chair
what am I doing wrong here all right
what am I doing wrong I was actually
good at agario this is [ __ ]
embarrassing
Ethan Bradberry come on oh my god gold
mine gold mine gold mine gold mine Ethan
Bradberry loser Birnbaum gerrae
he's Ethan Bradberry on the top ten no I
wasn't looking no no no that's son of it
yes yes yes yes yes man they've autofit
that the [ __ ] was that if true penises
go next to each other
that's good thing
what are you trying to reason Brad I was
[ __ ] Sara laughs OH
what you gonna do now what you gonna do
now what you gonna do now [ __ ]
yeah
get rekt rich oh you want that no that's
too bad hey you know when Ash Ketchum is
disappointed and and his hat it's just
like down and it's super dramatic EQ
some dramatic music like a Pikachu is
getting molested or some [ __ ] and - it's
just so pissed off that is that is me
right now
[Music]
I don't [ __ ] believe it I'm shaking
look at me I'm shaking I think it's time
brush it's time sashka come on such gay
let's say [ __ ] all get [ __ ] on your
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is it's a scam now
you are the one who will get the sucker
a [ __ ] oh you thought you were the
yellow [ __ ] of this town well guess
what you were [ __ ] wrong what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do
scooby-doo oh you just got Ethan
Bradberry [ __ ] mmm mmm tastes so good
buried oh my god oh my god oh my god
yeah oh my god this is amazing that's it
that's it I am a [ __ ] pretzel [ __ ]
[ __ ] you alright
I have returned stronger than ever
cooler than can be ready to defeat this
game let's go
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] yes we're actually doing
it take that
Skrillex oh this is the one
come on baby I'm ranked 13 baby we're
going for number one [ __ ] it's this
[ __ ] doing what are you trying to do
mate I'm number 10 we're going for the
number 1 spot oh god oh god what i do i
click i click the back button
oh god [ __ ] damn it this is the one
we're ranked number 3 burnwell babe
nation come on I told you bros I told
you we do it we're ranked too baby
we're gonna [ __ ] do this no one can
destroy me no
[Music]
I am immortal I am the immortal snake
finally finally we're almost there
almost there come on - give me number
one baby I can feel it it's in my veins
haters doubted that I couldn't do it but
they were we fought hard
I will return leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and next time we'll
destroy this game and as always stay
awesome rest amazing yes yes yes yes oh
oh [ __ ] you know straightly I just went
right in maybe Oh empty you say afk mg
one two three thank you for the snack
Brooke yes that is right yo exploding
nip went up to me